ah hope sorry
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding the weird
passive-aggressive side train just came
through hey guys it is Thursday here on
its grace and it is I wanted to call
this just the tip Thursday but a lot of
people have called their segments to
just the tip Thursday and I don't want
to copy other people so I'll figure out
a name anyway we're gonna I'm gonna
explain something to you today and I'm
one of my tumblr and I asked you guys
what did you want to learn how to do
today and someone said to ask somebody
to prom you're welcome
because I am going to ask that special
someone to prom before you ask your
potential date to start watching now hey
you I just love the way your parents
genetics have made your body the way it
is and also I love the way that nature
and nurture have made your brain the way
it is I'd like to dance up on that body
and grind up on that brain you are so
cool I mean your body temperature is
pretty average but your body temperament
is pretty cool I will respect you
and nurture you like the bone that my
dog is currently chewing and gagging on
think about my mouth cave like a safe
place for all of your insecurities and
issues I'm just gag on it until I
swallow it and then you're at a better
place we go to prom with me literally I
just want to put either my soft boner
and/or my supple but in your crotch
region so let's make that happen
and will you go to prom with me I just
want to put my super thick fabric tuxedo
boner on your super strapless generic
Sparkle dress you girls wear very sexy
things to prom I've seen it I have
cousins cutouts enough oh who knew that
like sad stomach was the new side boob I
thought it was side badge and now it's
side ribs tell you I can get a great
side of ribs Chili's that's not the
sound of waves behind me that's my dog
seriously you're licking and gagging on
a bone are you okay
that's symbolism for how I feel about
your personality just when I lick it and
then I want to try and follow it before
I should probably chew it and then gag
on it and then like puke it back up and
then I gag on it a few times just like a
dog in a bone let's go to prom